hello strange loop how are y'all doing
today
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is tilde that's pronounced like
Tilda Swinton or like the little
squiggle on your keyboard I'm a
developer evangelist at Twilio and I'm
here today to talk to you about using
declarative api's in an imperative world
what I'm going to cover is what is the
difference between declarative and
imperative programming paradigms why
you'd want to need to integrate the two
before I was a developer evangelist at
Twilio I was an application engineer
working on the atom editor so then I'll
send you into some nitty gritty details
about how we integrated some imperative
atom api's with react a declarative
framework and then I'll tie the whole
thing into the context of the bigger
picture with what we can use from the
history of language and framework trends
to make the future better
so what even is declarative programming
declarative programming is done with
declarations rather than statements what
that definition tells you exactly
nothing almost nothing
how about declarative programming
expresses the logic of a computation
without describing its control flow
still not really sold on that I came
across a blog post from a guy named
Tyler McGinnis that had the best
definition that I've seen which is that
declarative programming is about what
you do not how you do it so I'm going to
ask you a question and I'd like you to
think of both an imperative and a
declarative response so how do you get
to the st. Louis Arch from here the
imperative response would be head east
on Market Street towards South 14th
Street then turn right on South Tucker
Boulevard
because turn-by-turn driving directions
are imperative AF now declaratively you
would merely specify the address by
putting it into pretend this is like a
ride-sharing kind of interface because
declarative frameworks abstract away the
turn-by-turn directions and then you
just get where you're going but that
layer of abstraction is always there
because at some level computers are
still pretty stupid and they need us to
give them pretty clear and exact
directions on what to do so declarative
miss is just a letter layer of
abstraction the good news is you're
probably already using some declarative
paradigms without even knowing about it
can anybody tell me one anybody in the
front because I can't hear you in the
back yeah sequel absolutely
CSS you're absolutely right they're even
called declarations react yeah we'll get
to that in a second HTML is declarative
and pure functional languages such as
Haskell can also be considered
declarative and regular expressions one
big advantage of declarative UI
programming in particular is that it
gets it helps with a whole class of bugs
caused by state management so I first
started doing JavaScript UI development
back in 2013 at Pinterest and my first
real assignment was rewriting the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act forms
funsies not fun to use but let me tell
you what I learned a ton about state
management bugs and requirements
gathering from lawyers but for today
let's talk about a simpler interface so
this is like it's like a list of people
and you can add and remove them this
exists in reality on like every website
ever that's like please invite all your
friends I forked some code for this
originally from a code penned by Elmer
alberto camino let's take a look at the
implementation so it takes 13 lines of
code 13 lines of code to sync the state
with the UI when you add a new thing to
the list now granted we're using vanilla
Dom API is here but using jQuery
wouldn't even help you all that much but
worse than the verbosity is that it's
pretty darn fragile like if you have two
people with the same name and you're not
using unique data IDs you're gonna have
a bad time and this is just demo code so
if you think about you know the
additional complexity of like a
production application it gets even
worse so let's look at the same
implementation in react a declarative UI
framework and react you have an explicit
object representing the state so that
the code to add and remove things
becomes much easier to read and to
reason about it's more concise and less
error-prone so there's one more react
concept you need to know to understand
this talk which is props someone react
we have a component hierarchy where each
component has its own state and it keeps
track of that state but then parent
components can also pass down data to
child components in the form of props
and then the child components can then
rerender themselves based on those props
now note that this only works one way
children cannot pass data directly back
up to their parents so react is far from
being the only declarative framework
angular and view are also great I am NOT
into framework Wars I'm just picking
react because it's the one that I'm the
most familiar with engineering just like
life it's all about making trade-offs
and in order to do a good job making
trade-offs we need to know what the good
parts and the bad parts are so one of
the bad parts about declarative UI
programming well I mentioned earlier
that declarative this is another layer
abstraction
and what do we know about abstractions
abstractions are decadent and we're just
living these bougie lives we don't have
to care about the size of corners
anymore and I'm kidding but I did hear
someone over here say that abstractions
leak and you are absolutely correct
if you want to do something that a
framework doesn't have an affordance for
you are kind of hosed another problem is
that declarative Ness is frequently
accomplished via a domain-specific
language domain-specific languages are
another language to keep track of on
your cognitive stack so react you write
your templates in JSX which in my
opinion it looks just enough like HTML
to be confusing to beginners and not
beginners like raise your hand if you've
been tripped up by the capitalization of
class name because like yeah see I still
do that so now that you understand a
little bit more about the difference
between declarative an imperative API is
let's talk about how to integrate the
two
so first what kind of imperative api's
exists that you might want to integrate
with well there's video because I work
at Twilio now I am contractually
obligated to mention at telephony api's
there's mapping and GIS applications
there's animation libraries like WebGL
and three Jas and they're the api's of
the atom editor so Adam for those of you
who might not have heard of it is a free
open source editor built on web
technologies like HTML CSS and
JavaScript so it's a standalone desktop
application but it's built on top of a
browser which is pretty cool now if
you're integrating with imperative API
is that your team owns which I was you
kind of got to ask yourself some hard
questions like should we just rewrite
this imperative API to be more
declarative in our case we decided
against it because Adam has this huge
ecosystem of community packages which is
one thing that makes it really great and
if we rewrite the api's we
their need to force package authors to
upgrade or we need to maintain both
versions plus honestly it would just it
would have been a lot of work we didn't
want to do it you might ask why are the
Adam AP is so darn imperative
well Adam was originally written in 2013
before declarative programming got as
wildly popular as it is now speaking of
packages in Adam everything is a package
you get a package and you get a package
everybody gets a package the package
said I more specifically worked on was
the git and github integration that's
built into the editor so we're gonna be
diving into that what integrating react
into an existing application how do you
choose your entry point well there's a
couple of options say you had like a
fully imperative application and you
wanted to start sprinkling react into it
in that case you could start at the leaf
nodes and integrate small reusable
components such as buttons from the
bottom up but we Adam allows you to
inject Dom trees into arbitrary places
we're starting from scratch and we knew
that we wanted our whole tree to be
react so we took a top-down approach
something like this so we got our route
components and then you know some
children all up in there and then for
each imperative API that we cared about
we had a wrapper component that was
responsible for maintaining the
declarative imperative boundary so first
I'm going to show you the Adam text
editor which maps on to the text editor
API the text editor API controls things
like any state that's applied to a text
editor where your cursors do you have
any blocks of code folded currently do
you have soft wrapping enable you know
that kind of thing
I'm showing you simplified versions of
this code for sake of readability and
time so we use Adams built-in library
for pub/sub which is composite
disposable how many of you have used a
pub/sub library before cool well for
those who haven't
for pub/sub it's like you subscribe to
events and then you do stuff or fire a
callback when those things happen so
that did change cursor position prop is
passed down from the parent component so
the parent can force update and rewrite
of the whole tree when a cursor position
changes now I'll be the first person to
admit that this is not the most éclair
ative possible approach that I could
think of it would be more declarative to
actually lift the state and the position
of the cursor into the parent component
and let it decide to re-render itself
but with the way that the atom API was
that was kind of clunky because you need
to pull for updates you could have
multiple cursors so things get kind of
messy and we decided that we didn't need
to keep track of state that we didn't
actually need just for to meet some
arbitrary standard of declarative Ness
so your code doesn't have to be
perfectly declarative to work example
number two the panel component it's
wraps the atom panel API so a panel is a
container on the edges of the editor
window like this pull request review
panel that was shipped a couple of
months ago here we take advantage of
react Dom create portal to start a new
component trees somewhere else in the
Dom away from our main tree and it knows
how to render any children need
surrender here we're using should
component update as a performance off of
an optimization when should component is
a when should component update is
implemented your component isn't going
to update every time you get new props
so in this example we only want to
update a panel if it's being hidden or
shown we don't care about all those
other props so don't use component will
receive props for this kind of
optimization
it is a deprecated method and if you try
to use it you're gonna have a bad time
another important thing is to make sure
that components clean up after
themselves someone a components
unmounted you need to dispose of any
listeners and then act called the API to
actually remove
the component from the Dom so one
problem that was particularly gnarly to
solve was focus management so part of my
motivation for doing this talk was that
I didn't understand the focus management
code very well and I wanted an excuse to
dive in and really learn it the solution
involved refs refs are Reax dirty little
secret and they allow your reach in and
manipulate the dom nodes directly
imperative style reacts documentation
says are you sure you need refs dawg you
probably don't need ref but the use
cases that it listed were integrating
with imperative api's or doing focus
management since we were doing both we
figured that we were covered so you
create a ref by calling surprise create
ref and then you pass that ref to a Dom
element in your JSX
then to actually focus it you call ref
dot current dot focus but we had a
problem react doesn't guarantee that
refs are available until the component
is finished mounting but a component
doesn't finish mounting until all of its
children are mounted but what about when
a child needs to consume a Dom node from
its parent so the solution we came up
with is called ref holders ref holders
allow us to defer operations until the
Dom node actually exists so when the
parent we set the ref setter on our div
and then pass the ref holder to the
child component in the child component
we use this observe method to defer
actions until the Dom node actually
exists so a ref holder is an example of
what's known as a maybe monad pattern if
you're giving a talk at a functional
programming conference with this kind of
Sirte is then you're required by law to
explain monads don't hate me I didn't
make the rules but they're not as hard
as you've been led to believe they're
basically like a tortilla or a burrito
they're wrapper for a thing so you use
functions to wrap values and monads and
then you can even nest them inside of
one another kind of like some sort of
taco
nightmare burrito inception thing now I
used to be so confused by the whole
concept of functional programming
because all I heard was that side
effects are bad and they should be
avoided but then I learned that that's
not necessarily the whole truth
side effects are there's some really
important computery things like reading
from disk that are entirely side effects
so monads are just a way of signaling
hey there might be side effects here so
you can isolate them to certain parts of
the code base so they're easier to read
and reason about so maybe monad is a
special kind of monad and it's a wrapper
for values that might be null so you can
gracefully avoid a nullpointerexception
or cannot be structure undefined or
whatever that looks like in your
language of choice but this is where the
tortilla metaphor kind of falls apart
because an empty burrito is not going to
protect you from anything even the
emptiness inside your own soul so I came
up with another metaphor to explain
maybe monads
a social metaphor if you will so I had a
big crush on this girl for a while and
you know then eventually I asked her out
and I said hey I'd really like to take
you on a date but if you don't want to
that's totally ok I will never bring
this up again saying no can be really
hard and with good reason
like some people really don't handle
rejection well and it can even be
dangerous so I don't blame anybody for
being afraid of saying no so I wrapped
my request for a date in a mamey monad
to signal that of her desire to date me
was null I would handle that gracefully
and so I was like hey call me maybe
monad and she said yes anyway another in
our JavaScript d-wave explaining monads
is that a promise is a kind of monad
because a promise lets us write code
without worrying about whether
asynchronous data has arrived or not
similarly a maybe monad lets us write
data or lets us write code without
worrying about whether a data is null or
not and I'm not using the mathematically
precise definition of what a monad is
don't think this definition that I gave
you is going to be useful for you're
actually trying to learn how scale or
something my point is to try to make the
terminology more accessible to people
and then when it's time to learn more
than you can
so don't at me about category theory or
functors cool anyway focus adams focus
uses commands or to focus things and add
any use commands to move back and forth
between elements so that you can move
the focus part you can move focus around
in your Elinor editor without using a
mouse which is important for both power
users and folks you can't use a mouse
for accessibility reasons so let's talk
about the commands API Adams commands
registry lets you associate listener
functions with commands in a
context-sensitive way using CSS
selectors because maybe you want a
command to mean something different
depending on what part of the editor is
currently focused so the command
registry is essentially global because
we're using a style of event handling
known as event delegation which is
popularized by jQuery as the event
bubbles upward through the Dom all
registered event listeners with matching
selectors are invoked in order of
specificity
just like the CSS cascade so we have
this commands react component which
wraps the command registry API and
allows you to add new commands so
annoyingly because it's essentially
global because the event delegation
pattern and because react has that
one-way data-binding like I talked about
earlier where all your data can only be
passed down we have to pass down the
command registry from the root component
through our very deep tree to anywhere
that wants to be able to focus elements
in fact this is really a problem
throughout our entire code base at least
up until the point where I left where a
lot of the Adam API is just want a ton
of props that need to be passed all the
way through it's super annoying we at
the time that I left hadn't figured out
a good solution for it like we would
tend to use the spread operator on our
props but in my opinion that's a code
smell because the whole point of props
is for human readability it's so that
the people working on your code
you can look at it and understand what
the dependency is coming in from above
looked like so some solutions that we
had for fixing us were to use the
context API that was introduced in react
16.3 and maybe some hooks to make it a
little less repetitive so we move focus
around by registering atom commands in
our route react component which is the
code that I'm showing you here we have
these ref holders which can be passed to
child components to move the focus
around and then we also have an event
handler that keeps track of the last
focus position every time focus changes
to an element that's the descendant of
this component the event handler fires
and sets this dot last focus and then we
pass the route ref down any child
components that have focusable elements
these child components must implement a
method called remember focus to inspect
the event target and know where to
restore the focus to and then we
imperative leak all focus on the right
element another annoying thing about
this is that when you open up the
developer console the focus changes to
the console so we had to put in some
logging tracer snippets that were really
useful to our open source collaborators
working on the project with us so the
last imperative API I'm going to talk
about is get one important use case for
the git integration is that we want you
to be able to use git from the editor
and switch seamlessly to get on the
command line and have everything be in
the same state in order to do that the
editor actually shells out to the
command line and runs get commands
directly so that meant that we needed to
encapsulate the git API it kind of looks
like this so we have these model objects
which are playing JavaScript classes
that represent get entities such as
repositories and then we have you know
some some middle components then we have
a model observer which gives us a
consistent imperative API for fetching
data from the models the models emit
events and the model observer does stuff
in response to those events observed
model on the other hand is a react
component the
gives us some state where our data lives
as well as letting us to find functions
of fetch that data now be the first to
admit that like model observer and
observed model is a super confusing
naming scheme or at least I found it to
be so but I don't know I don't think I
could have come up with anything better
had I been the person to name this cuz
naming things is hard when we use the
observed model component we specify
exactly the data that we want from the
repository model in our fetch data
function and then observe model takes a
render prop so we can say hey here's how
to render the error state here's how to
render the loading state etc etc so now
that I've talked about some imperative
declarative API s that I worked on and
how to integrate the two let's put that
knowledge in the context of the bigger
picture
so if declarative UI development is
really so much better than why the heck
were we ever doing anything any other
way I thought about it and I came up
with three reasons reason number one the
web did not used to be so darn complex
I'm gonna pick on Amazon for a minute
but look at this page just look at all
the buttons and widgets and whatsits we
did not used to have full-on
applications
sitting inside of our browser things
have changed so much and just like
anything else there's positive and
negative side effects to this complexity
but also state management bug's become a
lot more of a problem the more complex
your state is so we need declarative UI
frameworks now more than we ever did
before in fact I'd even say that we have
come full circle because we were
building desktop applications like atom
like slack like Visual Studio code on
the electron platform so we're building
desktop applications on top of browsers
which is really cool it's wild reason
number two programming is fashion
in the sense that programming is
discourse it's an ongoing conversation
everything everything is a reaction to
the thing that came before it first we
had vanilla JavaScript and then we had
jQuery but made it easier to do things
like make Ajax calls add and moved class
names things like that and then came
react and the rest of the declarative UI
frameworks that were a reaction to
jQuery reason number three I was asking
the wrong question if you expand the
definition of we then we actually were
using declarative UI frameworks before
so cute cutey I don't know I didn't get
good consensus on how to pronounce this
so I'm just gonna go with cute but it's
a desktop framework that's been around
since 1995 it powers things like Adobe
products cute has been declarative since
2000 react was open sourced in 2013 now
again there's a bunch of other factors
that I've talked about like the rise in
complexity that made us not need
declarative UI frameworks as much until
now but I don't know thirteen years
still seems like a really long gap and
we could have picked up on this
innovation a little faster some
questions to reflect on what else can
web UI developers learn from desktop UI
developers you know insofar as the
groups are different now what can we
learn from back-end developers from
functional programmers what lessons can
we draw from the history of computing so
we can stop making the same mistakes and
reinventing wheels I've got to say it
would be a lot easier to answer these
questions if we weren't pushing older
folks of the tech industry it's such a
high rate ageism is real it's real and
we need to talk about it we're gonna
talk about it in fact ageism is
particularly real in Silicon Valley I
want you to do a thought experiment with
me so Mark Zuckerberg famously said
young people are just smarter I know
right that's
that's gross but think about like
replace young people with men in that
statement how does that change your
feelings about that statement
how would that statement maybe go over
differently in the public arena and I
know I know
the irony of dragging Zuck in the same
talk where I'm praising react is not
lost on me so Silicon Valley's 150
biggest tech companies have had more
accusations of age bias over the past 10
years than racial and gender bias and
speaking of racial and gender bias bias
compounds its multiplicative not
additive older workers who belong to
other under index communities are more
likely to face discrimination according
to stack overflows 2019 survey 75% of
professional developers are under age 35
that's an absurd proportion in order to
fix things we need to get to the root so
like what is the root cause of ages
thinking I have a few ideas
so like ageism is a problem that's going
to impact us all eventually right if we
live long enough we're all gonna get
older and I have a sneaking suspicion
that one of the roots of ageism is fear
its fear of our bodies wearing out well
I have some news for you and you're not
gonna like it but you need to face it
you're going to die someday and you need
to make peace with that reality I mean
alphabet even started an entire company
calico to solve the problem of death I
mean haven't anybody ever seen an
episode of Black Mirror even if it was
possible to solve death I guarantee it
would not go as well as you think it
would come on Silicon Valley grow up so
other than coming to terms with the
inevitability of our own deaths that we
can combat ageism inside ourselves what
can we do well for starters let's just
rethink the whole concept of aging
because it's a relatively recent concept
so according to history
ian's Carol Hebert and Brian cratan 200
years ago we didn't think of older
people as a distinct population but a
bunch of pseudoscience changed that so
in the first half of the 19th century
doctors believed that people were born
with a certain amount of vital energy
and that was a substance that you would
gradually deplete and that when
depleting it would cause you to age and
then eventually die and like obviously
that's [ __ ] right it's been debunked
but the same time it changed how we
think about things childhood is also
relatively recent invention we used to
just kind of think of and treat children
as small adults and not like I'm saying
we should go back to that child labor
laws are a good thing and I'm not saying
that ignoring ageism is gonna make it go
away it's definitely not just the same
as ignoring racism and sexism doesn't
make it go away
it's like socially constructed things
are still real money is socially
constructed but we still have to deal
with it
it's just that okay this is evidence
that we already changed the way we think
about aging once we can change it again
in a better direction but okay the root
problem is always capitalism is you look
deep enough but there's a sick kind of
feedback loop where the way that we
design and build products for older
people reinforces the idea that older
people are a problem to be solved and
since technologists are responsible for
shaping so many products shaping the
future so much we need both age
diversity and age inclusion on our teams
so how do we get there from here well a
lot of the next suggestions are of the
like rising tide lifting all the boats
variety we're anything we can do to help
older folks helps people in any
marginalized group so using objective
hiring criteria is one way to move that
needle so we started using interview
rubrics when I worked at Pinterest and I
was surprised by my own bias because we
all like to think that we're unbiased
but we're not and it's really easy to
have somebody have a candidate walk in
the door and decide you like them and
then decide that their answers are good
enough but it's harder to do that if
you've already decided what good enough
looks like before they've even walked in
the door
and written it down so medium actually
opens sourced some of their hiring
rubrics in an article you should check
it out but I wanted to give you a
practical example what this looks like
so when au might be the candidate can't
name any of the most common data
structures whereas a yes might look like
the candidate understands space and time
complexity even if they're not calling
it Big O another thing you can do is
change your language remove phrases like
so easy your grandma could use it from
your vocabulary now changing language is
super hard you're gonna mess it up don't
feel bad any kind of ally ship is a
process it's not a result so just keep
trying and eventually you'll get better
speaking of language you'll want to
audit your job postings because that's
another place that bias can creep in
there's a company called tech Co that is
using machine learning to help make your
job postings attract the most diverse
candidate pool that's possible caveat I
haven't personally used text i/o but
I've heard good things from the folks
who have another good thing to do is to
ask because there is no
one-size-fits-all solution for inclusion
it's always best to ask people how you
can support them I asked on Twitter and
I got a really insightful response which
is that you should aim for the same
emotional presentation and take away
especially if you're a supervisor like
people notice if you laugh and joke
around with other people and not with
them and it makes so much sense because
humor is how we bond or one way we bond
with other people right especially in
the workplace always use humor to
include to bring people in not leave
people out and finally we can stop being
so obsessed with shiny new things I
disagree that rewriting your entire code
base every couple of the years the way
we tend to do it is healthy we need to
get better at reading code instead of
writing it we need to incentivize
maintenance we need work/life balance
and like I don't think these things
directly contribute
to the lack of age diversity in the
workplace but I think there are like
symptoms of the same kind of short-term
thinking so let's review what we've
covered today and tease out some themes
declarative UI frameworks are eating the
Webby world included according to n PM's
most recent developer survey but it's
not just about growth it's about
satisfaction if you've ever built tools
for developers you know that we can be a
really tough crowd to please but
overwhelmingly people love the
declarative frameworks hopefully this
talk has given you a little more context
on why they are the jam and now you
understand some patterns for integrating
react with imperative api's what I
really want to emphasize here is that
there's no one-size-fits-all
fundamentally the way you choose to
communicate across the declarative
imperative boundary depends on the API
are trying to integrate with because the
question is how do you model the state
of your application in a declarative way
and now you have maybe some questions to
start asking yourself in case you want
to see any of the code I showed you
today in a little more detail it is all
open source and you can check it out at
the repository above finally you've
heard a few things you can do to combat
ageism within yourself within our
industry so I'd like you to reflect what
action are you going to take to make
things better both for yourself and for
our entire industry takes a village to
make a talk and credit where credit is
due is super personally important to me
I'd like to thank Alberto given us the
declarative and imperative UI code
examples I forked Tyler McGinnis for the
blog posts on declarative and imperative
that shaped my understanding the
definition of it evelyn MA so for the
call me maybe monad metaphor Katrina or
Chaco Joe Furman and Ashley Christian
for giving me feedback on the beta
version of this talk thank you to the
wonderful organizers of strange Lou for
all the hard work you put into making
this event
and finally thank you